what are some essentials that any
filmmaker that's still needs to know
that's like a minimalist approach so
you're using very few people on your
crew believe in yourself that's the most
because it's when you're you don't have
a crew to support you it's easy to just
fall out and just like I certain secure
about yourself but if if you you know
what you're good at you know you can
again it goes with the experience you
know by the fact that I've done 10 years
of stuff again and it's always always
the same process no team no nothing so I
enough shot in France I've shot
everywhere so it's just like it's
another project but for the first time
of course it's scary you know I mean but
you I don't recommend doing something
that big for the first time you know
start in your city start whatever go in
the desert find one location that you
can just learn from the natural element
how do you play with the Sun how do you
play with the win now do you play with
the sunset and stuff like that and with
the sound and and from that you're going
to learn and the more you're going to do
you're going to be ready to go to the
next level that's the thing people just
want to jump oh I want to do a
five-million-dollar like man just learn
something a little bit you know I mean
just go back and just be and there's a
thing if you learn and you go back to
the basic you're going to save so much
money seriously because you're going to
realize a I don't need 25 people because
you have to feed them you have to lodge
them you have to fly them so if you at
least go 10 a minimum because I was
shooting a do I shoot the film in Canada
or I should leave him in the States I
was counting yeah I have to fly 18
people to Canada just that was casting
yellow stain gram of my budget sound
like a I'm gonna fly myself so this way
just gonna cook like to grain or
something so we need to find ways to cut
your budget and once you know all those
little trick then it's easier but yeah
you need to understand what your
strengths weaknesses what you can do to
really to see what you're good at
otherwise you're going to fall down
you're going to freak out when you have
to deal with the schedule and then
people are angry because they want to
eat something in the now but you have so
many shot and so it's easy to just go
all over the place so let's say when you
were shooting outside like in the white
desert was sound the most intensive
thing that you were dealing with another
because the wind yeah the wind was just
eating the microphone for me i love the
visual as I had great that the wind and
everyone would look chaotic that's the
the storm was coming I was like that's
great but then I saw my boom guy with
the middle pipe in the win I was like
yeah he's gonna die or something but
then I was just looking at work and it
was like yeah it's gonna work but then
after that in Sandy's on we tweaked a
little bit to remove some of the rumble
into the microphone but yes sound was
that's the only thing because visual I
was like I'm good so for him was just
like yeah I'm good so it was that was
the main part and dealing with Dean
action that's the thing you need to be
able to flip yourself 180 degree right
away if let's say because it was
supposed to be beautiful and we should
you can see in the feminine where I'm
gonna tell you where but there's a
beautiful scene with the white desert
with the club but it's all sunny and
beautiful into a shot at the same moment
and then one hour later it was like do
me and because they're true the rumble
and the thunder was coming and was just
like okay we we have to adjust we cannot
wait and you need you cannot be freaked
out by that it's like okay cool this is
my shot list screw that go you need to
be able to improvise and be able to
understand what's going on in be in
control because if you start freaking
out in front of everybody everyone is
going to look at you like yeah I didn't
know doesn't know what's is what he's
doing and he's gonna probably suffer
their performance so we need to come cut
to keep calm but again he goes with
experience for ten years I've been
dealing with just natural light I hate
using fake lights the whole film was
shot with the red dragon natural light
and it gives a look you know and I
wanted that I wanted to have this kind
of a documentary feel and it just makes
something more more real a lot of if
there's grain and engineering I think
he's just bring some some coolness about
it but again experience so then when you
were in the castle let's say was
lighting one of the most detrimental
things that you're working with like I'm
sure it changes of course we're in the
castle no it was fun because that's the
thing the the castle it looks kind of
old but it looks beautiful at the same
time but they put like 10 million dollar
inside of a castle so there's lightning
everywhere we put some of the candles
sometime we fix it but still it's
it's candle you know I mean it's not
really the big spotlight or something
like that so lighting it was fine it was
fine so it sounds like your your advice
to someone that's going to do a
minimalist approach is first of all be
calm and and know that you're gonna have
to probably your your whole plan list is
in shot list and everything is going to
be scrapped to some degree it's not
freak out oh I I don't do a storyboard I
really don't so I love to just improvise
of course I have an idea I have like
first of all each scene I wrote a little
note okay wyd here close up here but
then when it's time and you see there's
always going to be problem for each
scene and first of all there's our club
scene in the film where the guy Tyler
arriving goes into a nightclub and so
the whole scene of him in the nightclub
was all done with one take and we shut
for like 15 minutes non-stop and 11 take
and any editing looks like it was
different but it was just a long run one
take again because we didn't have time
and that's something I was missing
sometimes it's just time but I it turns
out better because the nightclub scene
was one of the most fun thing to shoot
because it was me the guy Tyler the
actor arrived with his bike and we go
into the nightclub and you don't care
about anybody else you just go and it
was just me him going to war a little
bit you don't know what's gonna happen
you have lasers everywhere and it was
just so fun to just improvise because if
it was more control I'm sure it's gonna
be it would have been even harder to try
to make it control so the fact that it
just it was just chaos but in that chaos
I was just always sticking with my actor
came out beautifully and it sounds like
another tip then you're saying is start
small and build in an appropriate
increments don't go from 15 minute short
film to an hour long feature that you're
getting investors for that you really
need to work up to it totally and
because I think first you're not gonna
have the experience or sometimes you're
not going to have that style that is
your voice it's easy you can now you can
take cameras and shoot anything doesn't
mean that it's going to have this
quality of film or it's going to be in
the brand of it looks kind of cheap or
independent or low budget and investors
doesn't want
and one of the critic that I had went
from one of the review the famous like
oh this one looks more budget than most
Hollywood film I was enough that's kind
of cool to hear but at least you know I
was making sure that he looks good that
looks professional because you don't
want to make because people doesn't
doesn't think that it was done with
three people and 85 grand you think I
I'm sure there were a lot of people and
stuff like that but no so everything was
shot like a documentary but yeah it will
you need to you know one baby step one
step at a time to make sure that you are
comfortable that you can really nail it
and you know your style to make sure
that when you do something it's your
voice and not just like your generic
director that if we replace the director
to someone else is going to be exactly
the same thing and I mean so it's
important to to have your voice it's
interesting because you've said again
that you're impatient about certain
things but that you're very willing it
sounds like to really work up to to the
appropriate way to make the film like
from starting from from your first few
films you said that we're longer that
you really don't want anyone to see
taking them off line but that you really
are patient with the process of putting
your work out there and going and not
taking on too much yeah by being patient
I think you learned the game a little
bit and you see what works what doesn't
work for yourself for your film and when
I realized oh yeah I'm not that I was
not there but I was just like I need to
go back to kind of the roots oh and my
root of what I love and really found the
story that makes me tick and how can i
make it great for like three minutes and
one I can master the three minutes then
you can try to go to the next level but
don't try to be in a feature from right
away if you can master at least three
minutes because of course is going to be
a failure for sure so that's my advice I
would say to anybody at least just make
sure that you can say to you as you're a
short film that you are so proud and you
know that you killed it at least for
yourself that's yeah yeah I'm proud now
now I can go to the next level and
because I think that's what makes you
professional to just understand your
level of where you at and now I felt
that after 10 years and now I'm ready to
do feature film and I know the next one
is going to be even better in the next
one is going to be even
because you just learned so much every
time
you